Hallo zusammen, ich bin Stefan von der Flugschule Freewings und ich möchte euch heute etwas über die Aerodynamik erzählen.
Aerodynamik im Allgemeinen, aber vor allem gleitschirmspezifisch.
Die Frage, die uns sicher alle beschäftigt, ist, wieso ein Gleitschirm überhaupt fliegt.
Mir hat es seit dem ersten Moment, als ich als Kind einen Gleitschirm gesehen habe, nicht mehr losgelassen.
Ich bin immer fasziniert, wieso ein Gleitschirm aus Stoff und ein paar Leinen aus dem Rucksack uns in die Luft bringt und wieso man mit dem Ding fliegen kann.
Wenn man dem auf den Grund geht, findet man schnell heraus, dass ein Gleitschirm genau gleich funktioniert wie jedes Flugzeug, wie jeder Vogel auch.
Wir haben eine Tragfläche, die Auftrieb erzeugt und somit eine Kraft erzeugt, die uns in der Luft behaltet.
Ich vergleiche es manchmal mit dem Auto, man kann zwar alle Autos fahren, aber ob man jetzt wirklich versteht, wie die Kupplung und der Motor und alles genau funktioniert, ist meistens ja gar nicht so entscheidend.
Beim Gleitschirm kann es auch sein, dass man ein super Top-Pilot ist und eigentlich nicht genau weiss, was über sich überhaupt vorgeht.
Aber ich bin gleich der Überzeugung, dass es relativ wichtig ist, beim Gleitschirm zu fliegen.
Jetzt vielleicht im Vergleich zum Autofahren, dass man gleich die technischen Hintergründe auch ein bisschen versteht, weil es eben der Sicherheit beiträgt und auch, wenn man die Vollleistung aus dem Schirm herausholen will, wenn es dann später mal ein bisschen ambitionierter zur Sache geht, dass man mit einem Hintergrundwissen, was die Aerodynamik angeht, mehr herausholen kann aus seinem Schirm.
Angefangen hat das alles vor ganz, ganz langer Zeit.
Otto Lilienthal.
Hat da im 1891 angefangen zu tüfteln und hat schon die ersten, ja man kann eigentlich fast sagen, Hängegleiter gebastelt und hat auch die ersten erfolgreichen Flüge durchgeführt.
Er hat schon früh angefangen, die Vögel beobachten und hat eigentlich gemerkt, dass ja nicht alle Vögel einen Flügelschlag brauchen, um in der Luft zu bleiben.
Also er hat vor allem dann die grösseren Vögel angeschaut und gemerkt, dass die ziemlich gut gleiten können, ohne irgendwie etwas zu machen.
Und dann hat er angefangen, Störche auseinanderzunehmen, tote Tiere angefangen zu sezieren und hat dann gemerkt, dass eigentlich die Flügel von diesen Tieren alle ein gewisses Profil aufweisen.
Und hat dann das Flügelprofil angefangen auf seine Tragflächen zu übertragen und hat dann so herausgefunden, dass man so Auftriebe erzeugen kann, die einen in die Luft befördern, nach ein paar Schritten Anlauf.
Also im Allgemeinen gibt es verschiedene Erklärungsversuche oder Gründe, weshalb ein Flügel fliegt.
Grundsätzlich sind es drei Ansätze oder drei Grundsätze, weshalb ein Flügel Auftriebe erzeugt und uns in der Luft behaltet.
Der erste Ansatz ist die Theorie von Bernoulli und zwar hat das mit der Strömungslehre zu tun.
Ihr seht, wir haben hier ein Flügelprofil, welches, wie die meisten Flügelprofile, asymmetrisch ist.
Das heisst, obendrauf haben wir eine grössere Wölbung als unten.
Das beeinflusst, dass die Luftströmung obendrauf schneller zirkulieren muss, schneller strömen muss und dadurch gibt es einen Unterdruck.
Auf der Unterseite des Schirms ist genau das Gegenteil der Fall.
Dort ist die Luftströmung langsamer und es entsteht ein Überdruck.
Ihr seht, die Unterdrücke und Überdrücke sind aufteilt in unendlich viele Kräfte.
Das sind kleine Kraftvektoren.
Wenn man diese alle bündelt und alle Kräfte an einem Punkt zusammen nimmt, entsteht eine Kraft.
Das ist der Auftrieb, der uns ermöglicht zu fliegen, der eine Kraft gegenüber bewirkt.
Die Aufteilung ist noch ein kleiner Input für die Theorieprüfung.
Die Aufteilung ist zwei Drittel Unterdruck auf der Oberseite und ein Drittel Überdruck auf der Flügelunterseite.
Das ist ein wenig verwirrend von den Wörtern her.
Man muss schauen, dass man hier nichts verwechselt.
Irgendwo beginnt die Strömung nicht mehr diesem Profil zu folgen und beginnt hier hinten abzureissen.
Dem sagt man den Ablösepunkt, der hier hinten so kleine Turbulenzen und ein wenig durmisch die Luft generiert.
Zu dem kommen wir später noch im Detail.
Also grundsätzlich die Theorie von Bernoulli.
Strömungsleer, Unterdruck, Überdruck, der erste Ansatz, wieso der Flügel fliegt.
Dann das zweite ist das Rückstossprinzip.
Das ist Aktion gleich Reaktion von Newton, der herausgefunden hat, dass auf jeden Körper, der irgendeine Kraft einwirkt, eine Gegenkraft entsteht.
Und vielleicht habt ihr es auch schon probiert, wenn ihr die Hand aus dem fahrenden Auto hebt,
vielleicht nicht als Fahrer, vielleicht einmal als Beifahrer konzentriert darauf achten, was da genau passiert.
Wenn ihr nämlich die Hand geradeaus hebt,
dann passiert nicht viel, dann spürt ihr auch nicht den grossen Widerstand, weil die Hand flach im Wind liegt.
Wenn ihr die Hand aber so ein wenig schwenkt, in diese Richtung, gibt es eine Kraft, die nach oben zieht.
Und wenn ihr auf die andere Seite schwenkt, dann drückt es eure Hand eher runter.
Und dieses Rückstossprinzip nutzt eigentlich den Flügel auch,
weil auch der Flügel einen gewissen Winkel zu der anströmenden Luft hat.
Dem sagt man dann den Anstellwinkel, zu dem kommen wir später noch.
Und auch dieser verursacht eine Kraft, die eben nach oben zeigt und uns in der Luft hält.
Der dritte Ansatz, wieso das am Flügelauftrieb erzeugt, ist die sogenannte Zirkulationsströmung.
An der scharfen Hinterkante des Schirms entsteht ein Anfahrwirbel und diese Strömung wird dann gegen unten abgelenkt.
Und auch das wiederum gibt einen Moment oder eine Kraft nach oben,
die dann auch zu diesem dynamischen Auftrieb beiträgt.
Also das sind die drei Ansätze, die eben den Flügel in der Luft behalten.
Dann kommen wir hier zu ein paar Fachbegriffen, was Flügelprofile anbelangt.
Wir schauen jetzt den Flügel im Moment noch immer so im Querschnitt an.
Später schauen wir dann das Ganze als Gleitschirm, den ganzen Flügel über die Spannweite an,
auch die Leine und der Pilot, die Pilotin, die unten dranhängt und was das noch für Einflüsse hat.
Im Moment schauen wir uns einfach mal den Querschnitt an.
Und bei Gleitschirmen ist das Profil relativ dick.
Also ihr seht hier, das Profil dicker ist der Blaubalken.
Der ist relativ dick im Vergleich zum Beispiel zu einem schnellen Fluggerät,
zu einem Kampfjet, wo dann das Profil ganz flach und eher weniger asymmetrisch wäre und eher etwas dünner.
Also langsame Fluggeräte, die eben schon bei einer langsamen Startgeschwindigkeit schon sehr viel Auftrieb haben,
ohne dass man da eine riesige Geschwindigkeit zuerst generiert.
Die sind vor allem eher dick und asymmetrisch gewählt.
Profiltiefe ist eigentlich die Distanz vom vordersten Punkt und dem hintersten Punkt.
Im Gleitschirm Eintrittskanten und Austrittskanten, die ihr kennt,
die immer Begriffe sind, die man immer wieder mal braucht in der Flugpraxis.
Profilsehne ist eher ein theoretischer Begriff.
Das ist nämlich die Verbindung vom Vordersten und Hintersten.
Also nicht zu verwechseln mit der Profiltiefe.
Das selbe ist nur die Distanz.
Und Profilsehne ist wirklich die Verbindung von diesen beiden Punkten.
Dann kommen wir jetzt zu den Kräften und Vektoren.
Ich habe vorhin einmal kurz angesprochen, dass es an so einem Flügel mehrere Kräftevektoren gibt durch diesen Auftrieb.
Und diese lassen sich alle zusammenfassen in einen Hauptvektor, diesen Auftriebsvektor.
Später lernen wir dann noch,
das ist dann die Luftkraftresultierende, die zusammengesetzt wird von Auftrieb und Widerstand.
Zu dem aber später noch mehr.
Zuerst einmal einfach theoretisch, wie das mit den Vektoren aussieht.
Das ist jetzt so eine klassische Theorieprüfungsfrage.
Und zwar ist es so, wenn man Kräfte zusammenzählen will,
oder wenn auf einen Körper und den gleichen Angriffspunkt zwei verschiedene Kräfte wirken,
dann kann man diese Kräfte eigentlich wie aneinander hängen.
Ihr seht jetzt hier ein Beispiel.
Die Kräfte F1 und F4 wirken auf einen Körper.
Sie haben denselben Angriffspunkt.
Welches ist die resultierende R der beiden Kräfte?
Also links habt ihr das F1 und das F4, das ihr herauspicken müsstet.
Dann müsst ihr diese aneinander hängen und schauen, was das Resultat ist.
Und wenn man jetzt hier vom Start zum Endpunkt vom F1 noch das F4 hinzufügt
und dann den Startpunkt von beiden zum Endpunkt verbindet,
dann sehen wir, dass das Resultat so eine diagonale Kraft ist,
die dann eben die Richtung etwas geändert hat.
Das ist dann die Summe dieser beiden Kräfte.
Und somit bei diesem Beispiel das R2.
Dann haben wir gleich noch einmal ein Beispiel.
Wenn jetzt die Kräfte in die gleiche Richtung wirken,
dann ist es natürlich noch einfacher.
Dann gibt es nicht eine Diagonale oder so,
sondern dann kann man die Kräfte einfach zusammenzählen.
An der Prüfung zum Beispiel könnt ihr jetzt hier die Häuschen zählen
und dann seht ihr F1 plus F2.
Vier Häuschen plus zwei Häuschen.
Gibt dann die drei Häuschen beim R3.
Dann kann es aber auch mal sein, dass die Kräfte entgegengesetzt wirken.
Und dann, jetzt angenommen, die Kräfte sind genau gleich gross,
wir haben hier irgendeinen Stein und von beiden Seiten stösst irgendeine Kraft.
Wenn die genau gleich gross sind, dann bleibt der Stein genau an Ort und Stelle.
Und hier seht ihr jetzt, dass eigentlich das F1, das kleiner ist,
wie das F3 ein bisschen abschwächt.
Und auch hier wieder die Summe.
Dann kann man die Kräfte zusammenzählen und die Summe ist dann das R4.
Und dieses Grundwissen ist noch wichtig, um jetzt die nächsten paar Folien zu verstehen.
Wir haben hier wieder einen Flügel, die Profilszene, eingezeichnet.
Die ist aerodynamisch relativ wichtig.
Das sehen wir nachher dann gleich noch.
Wir haben die Luftkraftresultierende, die ich vorhin kurz angesprochen habe.
Wir haben den Auftrieb und den Widerstand.
Der absolute Wunschfall wäre natürlich,
dass man einen Flügel bauen könnte,
der keinen Widerstand erzeugt.
Also keinen Luftwiderstand.
Aber das ist halt einfach nicht möglich,
weil wir haben eine gewisse Stirnfläche,
eine gewisse Fläche, die gegen die Luft ankommen muss.
Und das erzeugt immer Widerstand.
Da können wir noch so einen perfekten Schirm bauen.
Wir wären nie, die kleine Widerstandskraft,
die eben dagegen wirkt,
wären wir nie ganz los.
Und der Auftrieb und der Widerstand kombiniert,
sehen wir jetzt hier auch,
gibt auch wieder so ein Dreieck.
Und die Diagonale davon,
das ist dann die Luftkraftresultierende.
Noch wichtig, links ist eingeblendet,
der Auftrieb und der Widerstand,
die sind immer im 90-Grad-Winkel zueinander.
Also die variieren nicht,
die sind immer genau im 90-Grad-Winkel.
Der Widerstand immer genau in der Linie von der Anströmung.
Also von der Flugbahn oder auch von der Anströmung.
Es kommt ja immer darauf an, wie man es anschaut.
Es spielt eigentlich nicht so eine Rolle,
ob jetzt der Flügel in einem Windkanal steht,
völlig theoretisch,
oder ob der Flügel durch stehende Luft gleitet.
Also schlussendlich ist es immer relativ
der Flügel gegenüber der Luft.
Der Druckpunkt ist auch noch wichtig,
um nicht zu vergessen,
der Druckpunkt ist der Punkt,
der die Summe von all diesen Kräften angreift.
Und die Gewichtskraft,
die ist immer gleich gross
wie die Luftkraftresultierende.
Also wenn wir schwerer sind,
dann brauchen wir auch mehr Auftrieb
und mehr Widerstand
und die Luftkraftresultierende wächst dann auch.
Dann geht es gleich weiter bei dieser Folie
mit der Anströmrichtung,
die ich vorhin kurz angesprochen habe.
Die Anströmrichtung,
die genau in der gleichen Richtung verläuft
wie der Widerstand.
Und da sehen wir jetzt den Anstellwinkel.
Da ist jetzt eben die Hand,
die quasi etwas schräg,
etwas angewinkelt in diesem Luftkanal ist
oder in dieser Luftströmung.
Und der Anstellwinkel,
das ist nicht der Winkel
von der Horizontalen zur Luft,
sondern immer,
ganz wichtig,
nicht zu verwechseln,
der Anstellwinkel ist immer
der Winkel vom Schirm,
also von der Profilsehne
und der anströmenden Luft.
Und die anströmende Luft
ist ja eigentlich nicht horizontal,
weil beim Gleitschirm
hat man ja immer ein leichtes Sinken.
Darum ist sie jetzt da auch so
leicht von unten eingezeichnet,
weil man sinkt ja immer leicht,
wenn man jetzt einfach eine neutrale,
unbewegte, ruhige Luftmasse anschaut.
Dann kommen wir zum Widerstand
eines Körpers.
Da ist noch interessant,
die Formeln für den Widerstand
und der Auftrieb,
die sind immer genau gleich.
Vorne steht jetzt W für Widerstand,
nachher haben wir ein paar Faktoren,
die dann eben den Widerstand ergänzen.
Hier ganz wichtig,
bitte nicht zu erschrecken,
ihr müsst für die Theorieprüfung,
für die SAV-Theorieprüfung
keine Formeln auswendig lernen
und nichts in diesem Stil berechnen können,
also nicht zu erschrecken.
Ich habe nur die Formeln aufgezeichnet,
um euch zu zeigen,
aus welchen Elementen
der Widerstand schlussendlich
zusammengesetzt wird.
Als erstes haben wir den Beiwert,
das ist die Form und der Anstellwinkel.
Da kommt es gerne darauf an,
ob es ein Flügel ist,
oder ein Auto,
oder irgendein Stein im Wind.
Da kommt es sehr auf die Form an,
wie ist dieses Gerät
oder dieser Gegenstand
am Windstrom ausgesetzt.
Dann haben wir die Luftdichte,
mit diesem Rohr,
hier geschrieben P.
Die Luftdichte ist natürlich
auch ganz wichtig.
Auf Meereshöhe haben wir
nicht die gleiche Luftdichte
wie auf 2'000 Metern oben,
was dann natürlich auch
den Widerstand beeinflusst.
Dann haben wir die Geschwindigkeit.
Achtung, die Geschwindigkeit
ist immer hoch 2.
Sie hat den Einfluss im Quadrat.
Zu dem kommen wir dann gleich noch,
was das genau bedeutet
für uns mit dem Gleitschirm.
Und das S ist noch die Grösse,
also die Fläche des Objekts.
Beim Auftrieb ist es genau das Gleiche,
nur der Beiwert verändert sich dort.
Die restlichen Faktoren,
sind die gleichen.
Der Auftrieb hat einen anderen Beiwert
und somit beeinflusst es dann
auch vorne den Auftrieb
oder die Kraft, die entsteht
und dann den Auftrieb ergibt.
Bei den SFA Prüfungsfragen
kommt immer wieder einmal
so ein Beispiel.
Ja, was passiert denn,
wenn wir eine gewisse Fläche haben?
Die verursacht einen gewissen
Widerstand im Wind.
Was passiert, wenn wir jetzt
die Fläche verdoppeln oder halbieren?
Und dort ist es immer relativ einfach.
Es ist immer linear.
Also wenn man die Fläche
von einem Gegenstand verdoppelt,
verdoppelt sich auch der Widerstand.
Wenn man sie halbiert,
halbiert sich der Widerstand.
Wenn sich die Luftdichte halbiert,
weil man viel, viel höher oben
zum Beispiel starten will
mit dem Gleitschirm,
dann halbiert sich auch der Widerstand.
Ganz, ganz grosses Ausrufezeichen
ist bei der Geschwindigkeit.
Wenn es um Geschwindigkeit geht,
verhalten sich da immer im Quadrat.
Also wenn sich die Geschwindigkeit verdoppelt,
dann verviert sich alle diese Kräfte.
Wenn sich die Geschwindigkeit verdreifacht,
verneinfachen sich alle diese Kräfte.
Also da müsst ihr immer bei diesen Fragen
nicht schauen,
dass ihr keine Flüchtigkeitsfehler macht
und einfach schnell, schnell anklicken,
sondern ganz genau schauen,
geht es um irgendeinen Faktor
oder geht es um die Geschwindigkeit
von dieser Luftströmung.
Sehr wichtig,
dass man da nicht reingeht.
Das ist jetzt gerade so ein Beispiel.
Ich lese jetzt nicht die ganze Frage vor,
aber wenn man 30 kmh
von der Fläche
hat,
und im zweiten Fall
90 kmh,
dann ist das eine Verdreifachung
der Windgeschwindigkeit
und eine Verneinfachung
des Widerstandes.
Also aus 100 Newton wird dann
nicht 300 Newton, wie man es vermuten könnte,
sondern die 900.
In unserem Meteor-Kurs
lernt ihr noch ganz
viele wichtige Infos
über die Atmosphäre
des Gleitschirms.
Beim Gleitschirm
wirkt sich das aus,
indem wir höher oben
weniger Luftdichte haben
und hier hat es weniger Luftteile
und unser Schirm muss sich
schneller durch die Luft bewegen,
damit er den gleichen Auftrieb erzeugen kann.
Das heisst, ganz einfach gesagt,
wir brauchen eine höhere Starkgeschwindigkeit.
Ihr seht, an dieser Kurve
nimmt der Luftdruck mit der Höhe ab.
Auf 5500 Meter
ist er noch
halb so gross
und mit dem Luftdruck zusammen
nimmt auch die Luftdichte ab,
die in unserer Formel vorkommt.
Die Luftdichte nimmt erst
alle 6600 Meter
um die Hälfte ab.
Aufpassen, dass ihr es nicht verwechselt.
Aber schlussendlich spielt es gerne
nicht so eine Rolle, ob es 5500
oder 6500 sind,
für die Theorieprüfung natürlich schon,
aber für die Praxis hat es den gleichen Effekt.
Es wirkt aus,
dass die Luftdichte abnimmt,
es hat weniger Luftteile
und irgendwie müssen wir
unseren Auftrieb erzeugen,
weil das Problem ist,
wenn ihr euch die Formel anschaut,
der Widerstandsbeiwert bleibt gleich,
die Fläche von unserem Schirm
bleibt gleich,
unser Gewicht bleibt gleich,
das heisst, der Auftrieb, den wir erzeugen müssen,
damit wir in die Luft kommen,
der bleibt gleich, aber unsere Dichte
ist nur noch halb so gross
und kleiner.
Das heisst, dass wir hier vorne beim A
beim Auftrieb wieder auf den gleichen Weg kommen,
müssen wir irgendwie das kompensieren können
und der einzige Weg,
wir müssen es über Geschwindigkeit machen.
Es kommt uns natürlich zu gut,
dass die Geschwindigkeit im Quadrat ist,
das heisst, bei halber Luftdichte
müssen wir dann nicht doppelt so schnell
rennen, sondern nur
die Wurzel von 2.
Da geht es jetzt aber schon fast wieder
etwas zu fest ins Mathematische,
das bedeutet, wenn ihr auf einem hohen Berg
oben startet, müsst ihr euch bewusst sein,
dass ihr viel schneller laufen müsst,
was sich ja meistens ein wenig widerspricht,
weil man ist vielleicht eh schon müde,
wenn man vielleicht zu gerne hoch gelaufen ist,
man steht vielleicht im Tiefschnee,
vorne geht es vielleicht steil runter,
also einfach im Kopf,
wir brauchen mehr Geschwindigkeit,
mehr Geschwindigkeit bedeutet auch eine weitere Laufstrecke.
Auf der anderen Seite sollte man ja auch
die Vorteile nicht vergessen.
Es mag dafür auch ein bisschen
mehr Wind leiden, wenn die Luft
abnimmt, also
es hat dann auch Vorteile, dass man vielleicht
eben bei einem 30er Wind als erfahrener
Pilot gleich noch starten kann, wo es
dann eben auf 1500 Meter unten
mit 30 dann schon ziemlich anspruchsvoll
wird und
ein Start nicht mehr möglich wäre.
Jetzt kommen wir nochmal
schnell zu diesen Widerstandsbeiwerten,
den CW-Werten.
Wie gesagt, es kommt gerne darauf an,
was für ein Gegenstand das hier ist,
ob es ein Flügel ist oder irgendetwas.
Wichtig ist, wenn man
die Gegenstände vergleicht,
dass man immer von der gleichen
Stirnfläche ausgeht.
Jetzt hier, wenn man die vergleicht,
geben die alle einen gewissen
Widerstand, wenn sie mit der Luft angeströmt werden,
aber die einen eben viel mehr
wie die anderen. Und das kommt eben
auf den CW-Wert links an.
Ihr seht, also zum Beispiel
die Halbschale ist 13 Mal,
die macht 13 Mal mehr Widerstand
wie dort der Tropfen
unten in der Liste,
der nur 0,1 CW-Wert hat.
Und hier ist auch
zum Teil
eine Theoriefrage,
wie vielmal kleiner ist
der CW-Wert 0,1
im Vergleich zu einem Gegenstand
mit einem CW-Wert 1.
Und dann wäre die Antwort, es ist 10 Mal kleiner.
Hier finde ich noch spannend,
wenn man den Vergleich
zu der Natur macht.
Die Natur sucht sich ja eigentlich immer
den Weg vom geringsten Widerstand.
Ob es bei einem Blitzschlag ist
oder bei einem Fluss, der sich durch die Landschaft schlängelt.
Es geht eigentlich immer so
der Gravitation nach und immer
dort, wo es halt am ringsten geht.
Und wenn ihr das mal ganz genau anschaut,
sieht es nämlich aus wie
ein Regentropfen. Und der Regentropfen
keilt ja auch nicht so vom Himmel
irgendwie wie als Brett, sondern
der keilt eben so vom Himmel, wie er
möglichst wenig Widerstand hat und möglichst
Ring zu Boden keilen kann.
Und dieses Wissen hat man sich
dann schon früh eigentlich
zunutze gemacht mit diesen
Windmessungen. Da hat man nämlich
Halbschalen. Wenn jetzt da alles
Kugeln wären oder alles so Scheiben wären
bei so einem Windmesser,
würde sich der nämlich gerne nicht bewegen.
Weil dann wäre die Kraft auf allen Seiten ja gleich gross.
Dadurch, dass es aber Halbschalen sind,
haben wir den Wind, der da drinnen
bläst, hat verursacht viel
mehr Widerstand, wie der Wind, der da drinnen
bläst. Und dadurch fängt dann
der Rädchen auch an zu drehen.
Und kann dann umgerechnet werden
in eine gewisse
Schwierigkeit. Auch hier wieder die Formel
unten dran, die dann den Widerstand ergibt.
Wenn wir fliegen,
haben wir immer wieder gewisse
Anstellwinkelveränderungen.
Normalerweise, wenn man einfach den Schirm
fliegen lässt, dann fliegt er ja
im Trim Speed oder in diesem
Anstellwinkel, wie der Schirm
gebaut ist. Oder eben je nach Alter,
wenn er altert und die Leinenlängen nicht mehr
ganz stimmen, dann wird der Anstellwinkel
vielleicht etwas grösser. Aber man könnte es ja auch
beeinflussen, indem man zum Beispiel
anbremst oder beschleunigt.
Wenn man anbremst, wird der Anstellwinkel
grösser, weil man zieht hier hinten
die Kante runter und die Verbindungslinie
nachher vom hintersten Punkt
zum vordersten Punkt
die sich dann natürlich
massiv verändert.
Und auch die Fluggeschwindigkeit
sinkt mehr und dadurch wird
dann einfach der Anstellwinkel grösser.
Das sieht dann ungefähr so aus.
Der Schirm fliegt langsamer,
CW- und CA-Werte
werden grösser. Das ist ganz wichtig
auch für die Theorieprüfung, dass ihr euch da
merkt, wenn der Anstellwinkel grösser wird,
vergrössern sich die Werte.
Umgekehrt, wenn wir
den Schirm beschleunigen und
der Anstellwinkel kleiner wird,
dann wird der CW- und CA-Wert
kleiner.
Ganz wichtig ist zu wissen, wir reden eigentlich
immer vom stationären Gleitflug.
Also ob wir jetzt stark anbremst sind
oder beschleunigt sind, es ist immer
stationär und der Schirm fliegt
eigentlich auf einer Linie im stabilen
Zustand. Und dann im
stationären Gleitflug ist der gelbe Pfeil
und der violette Pfeil, also unsere Kraft,
unsere Luftkraftresultierende
und Gewichtskraft
immer gleich gross.
Wenn wir jetzt aus voller Fahrt kommen
und anbremsen, dann wisst ihr ja,
dass der Schirm anfängt zu fliehen,
Höhe umbaut. In dieser Phase
ist unsere Luftkraftresultierende
schon einen Moment lang etwas
grösser. Dadurch
machen wir Auftrieb und gewinnen
auch Höhe kurzzeitig. Aber
nachher pendelt sich er wieder ein,
und dann sind wir wieder in einem
stationären Gleitflug. Und dann sind
die beiden Pfeile, gelb und violett,
wieder gleich gross und wir fliegen
ja, stabil und stationär hierher.
Dann kommen wir zum Staupunkt.
Der Staupunkt ist der Punkt am Schirm,
wo sich die Luft
entscheiden muss, gehe ich jetzt oben
durch oder gehe ich unten durch.
Das ist eigentlich so der Scheitelpunkt,
wo sich die Strömung aufteilt.
Und dieser Punkt verschiebt sich natürlich,
der bleibt nicht immer gleich,
um wieder mit dem Anstellwinkel
zu tun. Diesen Punkt
seht ihr, wenn ich hier
den Anstellwinkel vergrössere,
wandert dieser Punkt Richtung
Austrittskante hinterher.
Und hier seht ihr auch, wieso
beim Gleitschirm Zellöffnungen
so im vorderen Bereich
unten dran sind und nicht einfach
gerade vorne oder oben.
Weil in diesem Bereich, in dem wir
eigentlich fliegen, haben wir unseren
Staupunkt immer ziemlich
genau in diesem Bereich, in dem auch
Zellöffnungen sind, was absolut Sinn macht.
Der Ablösepunkt, der verhält sich
genau umgekehrt, also wenn man
mehr anbremst, dann wandert
der Ablösepunkt, wo eben die Strömung
nicht mehr am Profil folgen kann, immer weiter
Richtung Eintrittskante hoch.
Bis dann die Strömung irgendwann
hier oben komplett abreisst,
der Schirm keinen Auftrieb mehr erzeugt,
sich entleert
und wir in einem Full-Stall sind.
Genau, das ist schon das,
was passiert mit dem Staupunkt und mit dem
Ablösepunkt, wenn wir unseren
Anstellwinkel verändern und stark
anbremsen. Dann kommen wir hier schon
zum Randwirbel und
zum Widerstand. Wir haben jetzt viel
vom Widerstand gesprochen, jetzt schauen wir uns
das ganze System an und wie dann der Widerstand
ungefähr am Gleitschirm, am fliegenden
System verteilt ist.
Der Profilwiderstand, wie Sie hier
sehen, ist etwa 20%.
Die Leine sind etwa 20%,
der Pilot, die Pilotin ist etwa
20% und der grösste
Teil, da kann man sich irgendwie
schwierig vorstellen, weil das ist das,
was man nicht sieht vom Auge,
das ist der induzierte Widerstand.
Und der induzierte Widerstand entsteht
am Flügelende, weil
wir haben ja den Überdruck
und den Unterdruck und diese
Druckausgleichen wollen sich irgendwie
ausgleichen.
So ein Ungleichgewicht ist
nie gut in der Natur
oder in der Physik, das will sich immer
irgendwie ausgleichen und das gibt
am Flügelende die Verwirbelung,
die zum Teil auch relativ stark
sein können, also wenn
ihr jetzt an einem Gleitschirm
ganz nahe hinan fliegt, dann merkt
ihr, wie es ein wenig schütteln kann.
In der Landung darum auf jeden Fall nicht
empfohlen, um nahe aufeinander zu fliegen
und lieber etwas Abstand zu halten.
Je schwerer das Fluggerät ist,
ob es ein Gleitschirm ist oder
ein Jumbojet,
desto heftiger sind die Randwirbel.
Das heisst, wenn ihr jetzt in einer Landung
fliegt, hinter einem Tandem
fliegt, müsst ihr ganz vorsichtig sein,
weil dort sind die Wirbel
deutlich grösser, wie bei einem
Soloschirm.
Unser Ziel, wir haben ja am Anfang gesagt,
der Idealfall wäre eigentlich, dass wir
gar keinen Widerstand haben und nur Auftrieb.
Wie kommen wir dem etwas
näher? Beim Profil
können wir etwas herausholen,
dadurch, dass wir
den Schirm sehen,
hat durch die Zellen ganz viele
Wellen und Hügel, wo
eigentlich, wenn man Flugzeuge anschaut,
wo die Fläche schön glatt ist, ist das ja
eigentlich ineffizient und nicht so günstig.
Darum seht ihr auch Hochleistungsschirme
oder auch Intermediatschirme,
je weiter hoch das geht in der Schwierigkeitsklasse,
desto mehr Zellen haben
diese Schirme. Und diese Zellen bringen
eigentlich hin, dass eben diese Wellen
möglichst
flach ausfallen, also lieber
ganz viele, ganz kleine Wellen, als
grosse Hügel. Da kommt man
viel näher an den angestrebten
Idealprofil. Bedingt aber auch,
dass man dann das Gerät wieder beherrschen kann,
weil es dann einfach viel schwieriger ist,
zu fliegen. Den induzierten Widerstand
holt man raus über die Streckung.
Bei den Flugzeugen gibt es auch
diese Winglets, die man sieht,
die am Spitz des Flügels so hochgehen,
um diese Verwirbelung zu vermindern.
Beim Gleitschirm holt man es vor allem
über die Streckung raus.
Das heisst, auf die Streckung kommen wir
dann später noch, eigentlich
einfach eine weitere Spannweite und
eine kleinere Flügeltiefe. Also,
je mehr der Gleitschirm so wie ein
Sichler im Himmel ist und so schön
fein aussieht, desto
optimierter ist der induzierte Widerstand.
Das nächste ist die Leine.
Da will man natürlich im Idealfall
so wenig wie möglich und möglichst
dünne Leinen.
Das bringt auch wieder mit sich,
dass es mehr Knöpfe gibt, dass es
anspruchsvoller ist zum Fliegen bei einer
Störung und so weiter.
Also, ihr seht, alle diese Faktoren
bedeuten eigentlich, dass
der Schirm schwieriger wird zum Fliegen
und viel mehr Kenntnis braucht.
Und zu guter Letzt
Pilotin
macht natürlich auch ganz viel aus,
ob wir aufrecht drinnen sitzen
und eine grosse Angriffsfläche
für den Wind haben, oder ob wir
dünne liegen, möglichst klein sind.
Das macht dann auch gleich wieder
ein paar Prozent aus, die wir
optimieren können. Hier noch schnell
aufgezeichnet, wie so ein Liegegurtzeug
ungefähr im Windkanal aussehen könnte.
Also, auch hier seht ihr vorne
möglichst rund, dass
die Luft, die aufgeprallt ist,
diese Teile schön
rundherum strömen, wie ein Regentropfen.
Danach läuft es schön hinterher.
Im Idealfall
läuft das Gurtzeug hinten
so in die Spitze aus
und ist nicht gleich scharfkantig,
wo die Strömung abrisst, sondern
läuft wirklich in den Schlitz
oder in der Spitze hinterher aus
und geht dann hinten wieder zusammen,
sodass hier hinten möglichst wenig
Verwirbelungen stattfinden.
Und so kann man eben auch hier
noch das Maximum herausholen.
Also, der Beisack ist nicht nur,
dass es schön bequem ist und auch warm
gibt, es ist wirklich auch
aerodynamisch ein ziemlich grosser
Unterschied, aber auch wieder
anspruchsvoller zum Fliegen.
Dann kommen wir jetzt zur Begriffserklärung.
Als erstes reden wir
über die Spannweite
und wichtig ist noch zu wissen, dass
alle diese
Masse, die wir hier oben
sprechen, gibt es beim Gleitschirm
immer ausgelegt und projiziert.
Weil ausgelegt ist auch ein
Schirm ja viel grösser, wie
wenn er in der Luft ist.
Also, die äussersten beiden Punkte
gemessen sind in der Luft etwas kleiner,
als wenn der Schirm flach am Boden liegt.
Und das, was schlussendlich aerodynamisch
interessant ist und diese Fläche,
die wir in der Luft gemessen
über dem Kopf haben und Auftrieb
erzeugt, ist immer die projizierte
Fläche. Aber da
muss man manchmal aufpassen,
dass man vom Gleichen spricht, wenn man
sagt, ah ja, hast du den 20m²
und der andere
sagt, nein, der 18er und wenn es eben nicht
von der gleichen Masse spricht,
dann ist es unter Umständen
eben gleich der Gleichschirm.
Weil der eine von der ausgelegten
Spannweite oder Fläche und der andere
von der projizierten spricht.
Dann sind wir hier bei der Flügeltiefe.
Hier spricht man eigentlich immer von
der mittleren Flügeltiefe, weil
die Flügeltiefe beim Stabilo hier
ist ja viel minimaler
als in der Mitte und darum
berechnet man dort einen Durchschnitt
und spricht dann eigentlich von dieser
mittleren Flügeltiefe.
Die Flügeltiefe ist eben da,
die einen Schirm schlussendlich effizienter
macht, weil, wie wir gesehen haben,
ist ja der induzierte Widerstand der
grösste Widerstand und mit der Strecke
kann man eben den etwas runterholen.
Das ist das Verhältnis von der Spannweite
zu der mittleren Flügeltiefe.
Die mittlere Flügeltiefe kann man
nicht einfach heraus messen, da ist
ein Wert, der vom Hersteller her
gegeben ist. Man kann, wenn ihr
hier den Bruch anschaut, obendrauf
Spannweite geteilt durch
Flügeltiefe, Durchschnitt,
kann man den Bruch eben auch
erweitern mit Spannweite oben,
Spannweite unten und dann
gibt es unten daran Spannweite
im Quadrat geteilt durch Fläche.
Also entweder Spannweite
geteilt durch mittlere Flügeltiefe
oder Spannweite
im Quadrat geteilt durch Fläche.
Gibt dann den gleichen Betrag
unter dem Strich und da ist dann eure
Streckung, die der Schirm hat.
Hier nochmal schnell die Erklärung, also
projizierte Fläche ist
so übertrieben gesagt, wie wenn
jemand mit einer Lampenfolge zünden würde
oder noch besser zünden würde,
die natürlich viel, viel weiter entfernt ist,
wenn man jetzt gleich am Landeplatz
zum Beispiel am Händler ist, wo man dann
schauen kann, wie gross ist der Schatten.
Da wäre dann ungefähr so die projizierte
Fläche, so noch zum Erklären.